JONATHAN: Good afternoon.
Welcome to Talks at
Google in Cambridge, Mass.
Today it's my great pleasure
to introduce Ben Mezrich.
Ben is one of the rare
nonfiction authors,
like Michael Lewis,
whose books not only
have the urgency of
compelling fiction,
but which become part
of the zeitgeist.
We immediately think of
"Bringing Down the House,"
which became the movie "21," and
"The Accidental Billionaires,"
which became "The Social
Network," among many others.
Ben joins us today to talk about
his 17th-- is that correct?
BEN MEZRICH: That is correct.
JONATHAN: Yes, hooray.
17th book, "Once Upon
a Time in Russia:
The Rise of the
Oligarchs-- A True Story
of Ambition, Wealth,
Betrayal, and Murder."
It's also destined
to become part
of our national conversation--
a story of two men who amassed
vast riches after the
breakup of the Soviet Union
and what happened to them then.
Spoiler alert-- murder
is in the title.
The book has already been
optioned for the movies
by Warner Brothers and Brett
Ratner's production company.
And unlike the thousands
of times where we say,
oh yeah, it's been
optioned, this
is actually going to
be made into a movie.
Believe it.
So look for it on the big
screen before too long.
And please join me in
welcoming Ben Mezrich.
[APPLAUSE]
BEN MEZRICH: Thank
you very much.
Thank you.
Hi.
Thanks very much.
So yeah, my new book is
"Once Upon a Time in Russia."
But I figured I would talk
a little bit about how
I got here and the
previous books,
because when you
go to see a band
and they won't play any of their
big hits, only the new one,
you always get pissed off.
So I want to talk a little
bit about the older works.
I never really set out to be
a journalist or a nonfiction
writer.
I actually always hated
nonfiction growing up.
I was a big television
junkie when I was little.
And I would watch
the worst TV shows,
like "Saved by the Bell"
and "Three's Company."
And my parents,
fearing the worst,
wanted me to start
reading books.
So they made a rule
when I was little
that we had to read
two books a week
before we were
allowed to watch TV.
So at the age of 12 or 13,
I became a speed reader.
I would read everything.
And by the time I was
graduating college,
I realized I wanted
to be a writer.
So I graduated.
I went to Harvard.
I lived in Boston.
And I was a big fan of
Bret Easton Ellis and Jay
McInerney at the time, which is
actually a big mistake when you
want to be a writer,
because then I
attempted to be one of them.
And I wrote nine
novels in the year
I graduated from college that
were all deep, dark stories
that took place in
bars in New York City
and consequently was rejected
by everyone in publishing.
I got about 190 rejection
slips over a year.
And I used to tape them to
all the walls in my apartment.
I looked like a serial killer,
surrounded by rejection.
But eventually I wrote a
book that was a little better
than the rest.
It was a medical thriller,
because it was the dawn of "ER"
and George Clooney
was really big then.
And everybody was
talking about "ER."
So my dad is a
doctor, so I wrote
a medical thriller called
"Threshold," which none of you
have ever heard of.
But it was my first book, which
got me a second book, which
was called "Reaper,"
which again, none of you
ever heard of, which was
about a computer virus that
made the jump to the
biological world.
And people started getting sick
from their television sets.
And it was made into a very bad
TV movie called "Fatal Error,"
which still airs
on the SyFy channel
at like 2:00 in the morning.
I don't know if any of
you have seen this movie.
But it stars Antonio
Sabato, Jr. Remember him?
The underwear model.
I think he was on "Melrose
Place" for a while.
And he played a surgeon, which
was very believable casting.
I didn't know surgeons
did so many sit ups
in between all their patients.
But I remember
watching this movie
with my dad, who
is a doctor, again,
and there was a scene where
Antonio Sabato, Jr. is
leaning over a patient's chest.
And he goes, we've got
a subdural hematoma.
And my dad turned
to me and goes,
you know that's in the
head, right? [LAUGHS]
So it was the quality
of the work at the time.
But I kept on going.
And I actually ended
up meeting some
of "The X-Files" producers.
And they asked me to come
write for "The X-Files."
At the time I didn't drive,
so I didn't want to move to LA
and become an LA writer.
So I wrote a book called "Skin,"
which stars Mulder and Scully.
So if any of you are
real "X-Files" fans,
you might have seen this book.
But it was about a skin
transplant gone bad.
And this professor gets a skin
transplant from a murderer
and starts murdering people.
And Mulder and Scully track
the skin back to Thailand,
where I had never been.
So I wrote the whole book
from a Fodor's Guidebook.
Google didn't exist back then.
So it was pre-Google, I think.
And it showed what I was doing.
And it wasn't until I met these
MIT kids-- so I was hanging out
a bar, Crossroads,
which a lot of you
probably know Crossroads, which
is that bar across the river.
And there was a
group of MIT kids
that used to hang out there.
And I was introduced to them.
And they were like
your regular MIT kids.
They were kind of geeky.
Most of them were Asian.
But they had tons of money.
And it was all in $100 bills.
And the thing is, in Boston, you
never see $100 bills anywhere.
In New York, you see
$100 bills a lot.
In Vegas, they come out
of the ATM machines.
But in Boston, you
never see $100 bills.
And so I went up
to the main guy.
In the book I called
him Kevin Lewis.
In reality, his
name was Jeff Ma.
When I was writing
the book, he didn't
want to be known as
the blackjack guy.
And then we made
the movie "21," he
did want to be known
as the blackjack guy,
so now I use his real name.
I went up to Jeff.
And I was like, why do
you have all this money?
And he said, well,
come to my apartment.
I want to show you something.
And I went, and he had this
really nice apartment for a guy
his age in the South End.
And he shows me his laundry.
And in his laundry was
$250,000 in stacks of hundreds.
So immediately I
think, OK, this guy
has got to be a
drug dealer, right?
Because who has this much
cash in their laundry?
But he didn't seem
like a drug dealer.
He was a really geeky guy.
And he was really nice.
And basically he invited
me to Vegas the next day.
And so I went on
the plane with him.
And five of his
buddies flew with us.
But they all pretended they
didn't know each other.
And everyone was sitting
in different seats.
And we landed in Vegas.
And there's this limo
waiting with this driver.
And he's like, Mr.
Lewis, your car is ready.
And that wasn't even
this guy's name,
so this was pretty bizarre.
And we went to this
huge suite in Vegas.
We had like a swimming
pool and a butler.
We didn't even know what
to do with a butler,
and we had a butler.
And all the MIT kids show up
and start pulling money out
from under their clothes.
And they stacked
it up on a table.
And they said, we're
the MIT Blackjack Team.
And so I had kind of
heard of something
called the MIT Blackjack Team.
No one had ever
written about it yet.
There had never been
a TV show about it.
I thought it was
like a math class
where you learned how
to play blackjack.
But the reality
was this had been
going on for 25 years at MIT.
And a group of
students would train
the next group of students.
And essentially, this
group of six kids
had made over $6 million
playing blackjack.
And I was blown away.
And it was better than all of
the crap I had been writing,
but it was true.
So I essentially became
a nonfiction writer
to write that story.
And I'm not going to
go too much into it.
We could go into it if
people want to know.
But you've seen the movie
"21," or a lot of you had.
It was pretty much that-- 10
college kids hitting a casino.
Card counting is actually
something fairly simple.
The idea is that blackjack is a
beatable game because blackjack
has a memory, which means that
the deck changes as you play,
which is different
than roulette.
It doesn't matter how
many times you spin red,
it's not going to
change your chances
of getting a red or a black.
But in blackjack, if all
the aces come out of a deck,
you can't get blackjack.
So the odds do
change as you play.
And there is a time when
the player has an advantage.
And that's when there are more
high cards still in the deck.
So all that card counting
is watching the cards,
watching the cards, waiting
until more low cards have
come out.
More high cards are still in,
and then you raise your bet.
And that's what it is.
The problem is the
casino frowns upon it.
They don't want you doing this.
They don't want you using
your brain in a casino.
So if you get caught doing this,
you get kicked out or worse.
The MIT team would
spread college kids out
across the casino, one kid
sitting at each table keeping
track of the cards.
He would signal
in the guy called
the big player who comes
in, bets $10,000 here,
$10,000 there.
He's only betting on good
decks, so you're essentially
winning a higher percentage
of all those hands.
And then when you get the
signal it's no longer good,
you just keep walking
around the casino.
And so this system
works pretty well,
until eventually
you do get caught.
They start tracking one
of these big players
and realize this
guy's always winning.
And they actually
followed them back
to Boston, these private eyes.
They got a hold of
all these yearbooks.
And they took all the
photos out of anybody
who had gone to MIT
in a 10-year period
and used in all the
facial recognition
software that the casinos use.
So if had gone to MIT
in a 10-year period
and were betting big,
an alarm would go off
in the security booth.
And that's how they eventually
cracked the MIT Blackjack Team.
So moving forward, I
wrote this story up.
I wrote an article
for "Wired Magazine."
And the book was
about to come out.
And Kevin Spacey
read the article.
And I was sitting at
home and the phone rings,
and it's Kevin Spacey.
And he's like, I want
talk to Ben Mezrich.
And I was like, it's
not really Kevin Spacey.
And I hung up on
him, I remember.
And I called my mom.
And I was like, I think Kevin
Spacey is trying to call me.
And she said no, it's MIT
kids prank calling you.
Because they used to prank
call me all the time.
But really, it was Kevin.
I went out, and he said, I want
to make a movie out of this.
And we actually sent it
out to all of the studios.
And everyone rejected
it except for MGM,
which was the same casino
system that we had been hitting
with the MIT Blackjack Team.
And so it turned they wanted to
get some of their money back.
They were really
psyched to make it.
The movie premiere
was about to happen.
And we were doing this big
premiere in Vegas for "21."
And I was sitting at home, and
basically I got a random email
at 2:00 in the morning.
And it was an email
from a Harvard senior.
And it said, my best friend
founded Facebook and no one's
ever heard of him.
And so this was before
Facebook was big.
Well, it was big.
It was a hundred
million members.
And I knew about Facebook
because I'd seen it.
My wife was on it, and she kept
putting pictures up of parties
that I didn't know
we had gone to,
and I'd see all these pictures.
And I was like,
this is interesting.
I'd heard of Mark
Zuckerberg, but I'd never
heard of anybody else.
So I went out for a drink.
And it was in the
Bar 10 at the Westin
I don't think
that's still around,
but if you remember that.
And in walks Eduardo Saverin.
And if you saw the movie
"The Social Network,"
he looked a lot like
Andrew Garfield--
not as good looking
as Andrew Garfield,
but he was kind of a
less good-looking version
of Andrew Garfield.
And he proceeds to get
really, really drunk.
And he starts the
conversation by saying,
Mark Zuckerberg fucked me.
And I thought that was kind
of an interesting start
to a conversation.
And he began to
tell me that story.
And a lot of you have
seen "The Social Network."
You kind of know the story.
Two geeky guys who had a lot
of trouble meeting girls-- Mark
was really smart with computers.
Eduardo had made a lot
of money trading stocks,
and his family was rich.
And Eduardo had wanted to
be a member of this finals
club, The Phoenix, and got in.
Mark couldn't get
into a finals club.
And instead he went
on a date with a girl
that went really bad.
He got home.
He drank a bunch of
beers and then hacked
into all these
computers at Harvard,
got all these pictures
of every girl on campus,
and made a site where you
could vote on who the hottest
girl at Harvard was.
At the time, he also
had a little thing
where you could compare
the girls to farm animals.
And when he got in
trouble for this,
he said, well, the girls were
beating the farm animals.
So he thought no one
should be mad at him.
But it shows you the social
state he was in at the time.
Basically, he leaked
this program out
to a bunch of friends.
It spread all over campus.
It actually got him
in a lot of trouble.
He nearly got kicked
out of Harvard.
And that's when he caught the
attention of the Winklevoss
twins.
You couldn't invent these
guys if you wanted to, right?
6 foot 5" identical
twin Olympic rowers.
They were the cool
kids on campus.
They always wore suits to class.
I remember meeting them in
a hotel room in New York.
And Cameron or Tyler--
I don't know which one.
You can't tell them apart.
He was like, you
look at us, and you
think we've got to be the
bad guys in this story.
Because we look like the
guys in an '80s movie who
would be chasing the
karate kid around
dressed as skeletons, right?
I remember I put that
line into the book.
And then Aaron Sorkin put
that line into the movie.
And then when the
movie came out,
Ralph Macchio actually
called me and was
excited that the
karate kid was being
talked about in this movie.
So I thought that was cool.
[LAUGHTER]
But the Winklevoss saw Mark
Zuckerberg getting in trouble
in all the papers for this
website he had written.
And they were working
on their own website
in their dorm
room, which is what
I loved about Harvard
at that time period,
is even the jocks were making
computer programs in their dorm
room.
They were working on a
dating website called
TheHarvardConnection.com.
And the idea behind it was to
help women meet Harvard men.
Harvard men spent a
lot of time trying
to help women meet Harvard men.
This was their idea.
The problem was they didn't
know anything about computers.
So they wanted to hire
someone that could
make this program for them.
They see Mark Zuckerberg
in the newspaper.
And they say, we're
going to hire this guy.
Now, Mark didn't think
much of their idea.
He thought it was stupid.
He thought they were stupid.
But he thought, hanging out
with the cool guys on campus--
that's cool, so I'm
going to do that.
So he basically led them on.
He went to his friend
Eduardo, his roommate,
and basically said, Eduardo,
I've got an idea for a website.
People will put
their own stuff up.
We won't get in trouble.
If you put up the
money-- and at the time,
it was $1,000-- you
can be CFO and you
can have 30% the company.
Now, it's two college
kids in a dorm room.
There's no lawyers.
There's no contracts
or anything like that.
And Eduardo says
sure, here's $1,000.
Mark locks himself in a room.
He writes Facebook.
And the rest is kind of history.
It rolls out.
Everyone at Harvard joins.
It starts going from
college to college.
When it hits
Stanford, that's when
Sean Parker joins
the story-- you know,
the Justin Timberlake character.
He was the cool kid
of Silicon Valley.
Some of you might know Sean.
He dresses in Armani.
He's got girls on his arms.
But he also has an
EpiPen in his pocket
because he's allergic
to everything.
So he's got that kind of mix
of cool and geek going on.
Eduardo thinks he's
a snake oil salesmen.
Eduardo doesn't
like Sean at all.
Mark is totally into Sean.
He idolizes Sean.
Mark moves off to California.
Eduardo stays behind.
Sean ends up living
with Mark in a house,
and basically is starting to
take it to the next level.
Eduardo feels like he's being
left behind, gets very upset,
and he freezes the bank
accounts of Facebook.
At this point, he put
$18,000 into the company.
He freezes it.
So Sean takes Mark over
to Peter Thiel and says,
we need some money.
And Peter Thiel give them
half a million dollars,
but says, well, who's this
guy listed as your CFO who's
not even here?
We need to get rid of
this guy, basically.
So they invite Eduardo
out to California.
Eduardo shows up and walks
into a room full of lawyers.
He thinks that
they're his lawyers.
They're actually
Facebook's lawyers.
He signs a document which
dilutes him to zero.
Then he goes back to Boston.
The Winklevoss, meanwhile, are
off rowing in Henley or London
or whatever.
And they realize
that Facebook is huge
and they're not involved.
They sue Mark.
Eduardo sues Mark.
And that's when I
came into the story.
Eduardo wasn't supposed
to be talking to anybody.
He was in the midst of
this massive lawsuit.
He was being ignored.
He wasn't getting anywhere.
So he thought by
talking to a writer,
he could maybe force
Facebook to settle with him.
I hung out with Eduardo.
I wrote a 14-page book proposal.
And my book proposal
leaked onto the internet.
It landed on a site
called Gawker.com.
And on that day, all
hell broke loose.
Facebook settled
with Eduardo for what
eventually became $4 billion.
Part of the settlement
agreement says,
you may never speak
to Ben Mezrich again,
because they were hoping to
stop the book from happening.
So Eduardo sends me a
legal restraining order
that I can never
speak to him again
and runs off to
Singapore, breaks
up with the girl he was dating
because she was my wife's best
friend.
And listen, I understand,
for $4 billion,
I would never speak
to me again, too.
I get it.
But he disappeared,
and I have not
spoken to Eduardo ever since.
Facebook comes to me and is
like, what are you writing,
all this kind of stuff.
I start going back
and forth with them,
that I want to talk to Mark.
Let me interview.
Mark would not let
me interview him.
He knew he couldn't control
what I was going to write.
He knew the Winklevoss
were talking to me.
So he did not want
any involvement
with it, which is his right.
Basically, Aaron Sorkin also
saw this online and said,
I want to write this
as my next movie.
David Fincher saw
it online and says,
I want to direct this as my next
movie, which is all wonderful,
except for I hadn't
actually written a book yet.
So I locked myself in
a hotel room in Boston
and I wrote the book
in about three months.
And Sorkin came out, and
he wrote the screenplay
about three weeks after that.
And it became "The Social
Network," which was awesome.
Had it not been for
"The King's Speech,"
it would have won
all the Oscars.
But "The King's Speech"
was very good, too.
But anyway, this is where
my career was at this point.
And this is how we get to
"Once Upon a Time in Russia."
Brett Ratner, the director,
who did the "Hercules"
movie, "The Rush
Hour," movies, he
was a producer on
the movie "21."
So I had known him
through the years.
And he would often call
me with ideas for stories.
They were always dangerous.
They were always like gun
runners in Miami, or people
who had been selling drugs
out of the back of their house
or whatever.
And I would say, Brett, how
dangerous is this story?
And he'd always say, it's
like an eight out of 10.
And I said, oh, I don't want
to do an eight out of 10.
So anyways, two years
ago, he calls me up again.
And he says listen,
Ben, I got a story.
It's really good.
You need to come to London
and meet some people.
And he didn't tell
me what it was.
And I was like,
ugh, really, I got
to fly all the way to London?
He's like, Ben, trust
me, it's a great story.
So I flew to London.
I landed in London.
I went straight
to this restaurant
where we were meeting.
And there were all
these security people
outside, like a
dozen security, all
these black Mercedes limousines.
And I get in, and
across the room
was an oligarch, so a
real Russian oligarch,
someone that is very famous.
And I walk in.
I'm like, no fucking way.
That was my first response.
I was like, Brett, I don't
want to be involved with this.
This is too big.
These people are very scary.
It's this intense, huge story.
But I sat down and I
began to hear this story.
And it was really mind-boggling.
It's this incredible drama about
these two men, Boris Berezovsky
and Roman Abramovich.
And through them, you
get the whole story
of where Putin came from,
the fall of communism
and the rise of capitalism,
and this incredible creation
of wealth.
At one point in time, seven
men owned 50% of Russia's GDP.
And these were men from
nowhere with no backgrounds.
They were poor.
Many of them were Jewish
in an anti-Semitic society.
They had built these
incredible fortunes off
of this chaotic, turbulent shift
from communism to capitalism.
So after going back and
forth a number of times,
I did decide to write it.
And we ended up selling
the movie and the book.
And so the movie's
going to be with Warner.
And just to give you a
brief idea of the story--
because I don't want
to give too much of it
away, because not
everyone in the US
knows these names that well.
Boris Berezovsky was
essentially a car salesman.
And in the early '90s,
he was a mathematician
by background, a brilliant
man, but he was an outsider.
He really didn't have
anything behind him.
He wasn't a member
of a communist party.
And when communism
fell, capitalism
was quickly shoved into
place by Boris Yeltsin,
who was the president.
The idea was that
there was this fear
that communism would come back.
So they wanted to quickly place
all of the resources of Russia
into the hands of
private people,
into businesses that were
owned by private citizens,
so that it became
capitalism overnight.
So essentially, there
was this free for all.
And a man like Boris
Berezovsky, who
was very crafty and very smart,
was able to find a way in.
He became a car
dealer, who essentially
became one of the
wealthiest men in Russia
by opening up car dealerships
all over the country.
And that's what he was doing.
In 1994, he was in
his car riding out
of one of his companies
when the car was blown up.
He was nearly killed.
His driver was decapitated.
It was this
assassination attempt.
He actually caught fire,
but was able to survive,
had a lot of bandages
on them, and basically
decided he needed to
get into politics.
Because the only way to
protect yourself in Russia
was to be a politician.
So he wormed his
way into the Kremlin
and became part of the inner
circle of Yeltsin-- the Family
with a capital F.
It was at this point
that he met Roman Abramovich.
He was on a yacht
in the Caribbean.
And Roman Abramovich was
a 26-year-old toymaker.
He used to make rubber
ducks and baby's toys.
Came from nowhere, again--
an orphan from Siberia,
no background at all.
And he was on this boat.
He met Berezovsky, and
he pitched him the idea
of privatizing an oil company.
Basically, there
was all these pieces
of an oil company owned
by the Communist Party,
essentially, that had
to become private.
And they decided that they
would be the people who did it.
So Boris Berezovsky
became his roof.
In Russian, the word
is the [? cretia ?].
You have a roof above
you that protects you.
It comes from the
mafia, but it moved
into politics and business.
If you had someone above
you protecting you,
you could build a company.
So again, just like
the Facebook story,
there were no shares
changing hands.
There were no
contracts being signed.
Berezovsky was in the Kremlin
and would help out on that end.
And Roman would do the legwork
and be the businessman.
And they built what became
the second largest oil
company in Russia, Sibneft.
In this process,
they got wealthier
and wealthier and wealthier.
Abramovich would have to
make payments to Berezovsky.
Suitcases full of money--
these were the payments.
They would show
up with $3 million
in a suitcase, $5
million in two suitcases.
And these payments could come
once a week, twice a week.
One year they ended up
giving him $100 million.
It was crazy amounts
of money-- wealthier
and wealthier and wealthier.
But at the same time,
Yeltsin was getting ill.
He was getting sick.
And the people behind
him, these oligarchs,
realized that Yeltsin
was going to die
and they needed to put someone
in his place, a new president.
And that's where they
found Vladimir Putin.
Putin was this nobody.
He was a low level KGB
agent in St. Petersburg.
He worked for the mayor
of St. Petersburg.
He was known for being
incredibly loyal.
And that's all he really had
going for him at the time.
Nobody knew anything about him.
But they wanted to place someone
in power who was very loyal.
And they figured this is a cog.
This is someone we can control.
So they essentially
handpicked Putin,
and they made him president
of Russia after Yeltsin.
The minute he took over,
everything changed.
A week later, he
invited these oligarchs
to Stalin's old house.
You could actually see
bullet holes in the wall
where people had been
lined up and shot.
The oligarchs were
sat down at a table.
And Putin got in front
of them and said, listen,
you've all made a lot of money.
You've done very, very well.
You can keep your money,
but stay out of my way.
And from that moment on, the
oligarchs were given a signal.
They had two choices.
Keep your money and do whatever
Putin says, or go against me
and you're either
exiled or dead.
And that's exactly
what happened.
Berezovsky he went
up against him
and eventually ended
up exiled to London.
And then-- well, I don't
want to give too much away.
But you really pretty much know
this if you've read any news.
He's eventually found
hanging a year ago.
Meanwhile, Abramovich
stays in good with Putin,
grows and grows and grows.
He ends up offering
Berezovsky $1.3 billion.
He hands him a check
for $1.3 billion
on an airfield in
France and says,
basically, here's your payoff.
Now you're finished.
And Berezovsky took the
money and then regretted it
and sued Abramovich, in the
largest lawsuit in history,
for $6 billion in
the legal courts,
and eventually lost the case
and then was found hanging.
So this is the story.
It's really intense.
It's really huge.
Throughout the story, there's
the character of Litvinenko
some of you might
have heard of, the guy
who was polonium poisoned
a few years back.
He actually moonlit.
He worked as security
for Berezovsky
and also was a KGB
agent under Putin.
So he's a character that
links all of these characters
together.
But in the end, he met his fate.
He drank a cup of tea that
was laced with polonium
and died in a very
horrible matter.
On his deathbed,
he blamed Putin.
But there's a lot of
mystery surrounding it,
which I get into in the
book a little bit more.
In the end, the story was
intense and crazy to write.
I do remember one time
Brett and I were sitting
at a table with these people.
And Brett goes, are we going
to get killed for writing this?
And the oligarch goes,
you watch too many movies.
And then Brett said, well,
what if we say the wrong thing?
And he said, don't
say the wrong thing.
So it's as simple
as that, right?
So I figured at this point--
I know it's a big story,
but I tell it in a small way.
If you read the book
it's a thriller,
James Bond-esque a little bit.
And all of it is true,
built on these sources.
But I figure I'd open it up
to questions at this point.
I know my career spans
a number of topics
that you may or may
not be interested in.
And I'd love to hear what
anybody wants to know.
So-- sure.
AUDIENCE: So hello.
The question was,
you seem to stumble
upon these amazing stories,
or they are able to find you.
I'm just wondering how
you're so plugged in
and are able to identify these
things that other people just
say, eh, not a big deal.
BEN MEZRICH: Yeah, right.
Well, I have all
these criteria I look
at before I get into a story.
And I want to first make
clear that I don't actually
find these stories.
They come to me.
Ever since "Bringing Down
the House" and "21" came out,
every college kid who does
something stupid emails me.
Every college kid who does
something cool also emails me.
All of these stories
started to come
and be sent to me because
of that movie and that book.
The idea of a bunch of kids
taking on a casino really
caught something in the way
people who don't love authority
or are very smart want to
do things different think.
So people come to
me with stories.
And I look into the story,
and I try and figure out
not what's going to be hot or
what's going to be a big story,
but what is intriguing
to me because it
has these themes of exotic
locations, something
using your brains.
I don't want criminals.
I want someone to do
something through ambition,
but is super smart and figures
out a way to game the system.
All of my books have that theme.
And Mark Zuckerberg,
really, he changed a system
that didn't work for him.
He was a geeky guy you
couldn't meet girls.
As much as he
denies that, that's
really what his story was.
And he wanted to create
a world where people like
him could be socially stars.
And he created Facebook to
make a social world that
worked for Mark Zuckerberg.
The oligarchs saw
an opportunity.
They were incredibly
ambitious and smart.
They were willing
to kill people.
But they essentially
built these fortunes
because they looked at this
crumbling system and said,
I know a way to win here.
And so I'm always
intrigued by that.
So it's not that I'm
trying to guess what's
going to be the next hot
thing, or is this going
to work for a big audience.
I do, however,
never start a book
if I don't think
there can be a movie.
Because I feel like if
it can't be a movie,
it's probably not going
to be a good book.
I know there's a
lot of writers who
don't think that way
and probably don't
like me thinking that way.
But I do feel like
the stories I choose,
they work because they
could also be on the screen.
They are very cinematic.
They have those Shakespearean,
dramatic themes to them.
So I really look
for those criteria
when I'm trying to find
something to write.
But yeah, it's tricky.
I mean, you never know
what's going to work
and what's not going to
work when you sit down.
So I remember when I
wrote the Facebook book,
I sent it to Kevin
Spacey and Dana
Brunetti, who runs his company.
And one of their first comments
was, yeah, it works as a book.
But I don't know if I
see this is a movie.
And my mom said the same thing.
She's one of my first
readers, always.
And she's like, yeah, no
one cares about Facebook.
And you know, maybe no one
did care about Facebook.
But suddenly they did when it
was presented in the right way.
So it's just a matter of
figuring out these themes that
really send a story forward.
Sure.
Anybody?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So with Russia
getting isolated with sanctions
with the standoff
over Ukraine, there
is a general
sentiment-slash-hope
that the oligarchs might push
Putin away from that course.
What are your thoughts on that?
BEN MEZRICH: I actually
think there's a misconception
about Putin and the oligarchs.
In the olden days, yes, the
oligarchs ran the country.
There were seven men who
owned 50% of the GDP.
They propped Yeltsin up.
They created Putin.
But everything flipped.
Putin is above
the oligarchs now.
It's not that the
oligarchs are going
to gather together
and get rid of Putin.
Putin gets rid of the oligarchs.
And I think there's a
misconception in the West
about Putin, how strong he is.
He's very strong.
The people in Russia love him.
The oligarchs who have stayed
in control and power love Putin.
They're known as
Putin's cash register.
When he wants money, he asks
for it and they give it to him.
So the idea that
sanctioning Russia
is going to make the oligarchs
take Putin down is incorrect.
It's going to make
Putin react violently
in a lot of different
ways, because he's
a very strong leader.
He believes very
strongly that Russia
shouldn't be under the control
of the rest of the world.
So I don't see that
happening, personally.
I mean, I guess
I could be wrong.
I'm not a Russian expert
in a lot of things, other
than this particular story.
I really feel that
backed into a corner,
Putin becomes stronger
and lashes out more.
So I don't know what
the answer is there.
I do think that economically
the country is being hurt badly.
The oil prices going down
is dramatically destroying
oligarchs' wealth as well
as the Russian wealth.
But Putin's power
base seems to be
getting stronger, not weaker.
The oligarchs who go up against
him don't end up well, right?
They end up dead, or
they end up broke,
or they end up in prison.
And that continues.
I don't know how that changes.
You see a lot of
oligarchy money coming
into New York and London.
The reason is the oligarchs
are afraid of what's
going on in Russia-- not for
Putin, but for themselves.
They think, OK, I'm going to
go by $100 million house in New
York so I have money when
I have to get out of there.
It's not the other way around.
It's not, let's take this
money and take Putin down.
So I don't know that is the
right way to look at it.
I know that that is what
people want to happen.
But in the real world, Putin is
a very popular man in Russia.
He's more popular than any
president we've ever had.
And that's not because they're
forced to vote for him.
People love a strong
leader in a strong country.
And that's what they
look to Putin for.
So that's my opinion.
I don't know.
I mean, I'm not
an expert on that.
So there are people who
will say differently.
But that's what I
think's happening.
AUDIENCE: I just wanted to ask,
in writing this most recent
book, "Once Upon a
Time in Russia," did
you have a chance to
personally interact
with some of the oligarchs?
BEN MEZRICH: I did.
I don't go into who my
sources are specifically.
I definitely had
first readers who
read every line in this
book who were involved very
heavily in the story, so there
were at least one oligarch
involved.
I will say this is
the first book I've
written where I didn't
want to uncover anything
that wasn't already known.
And I wasn't like, I want
to find some secret tie
between Litvinenko's
murder and somebody
in particular, because that
wouldn't necessarily be good.
But in general, I had
some amazing sources.
I also had all these
incredible court documents.
There were all these
depositions taken
in this trial between
Berezovsky and Abramovich,
depositions all the way
to Putin's head of staff.
Abramovich is deposed for
a thousand pages in there.
And I received this document.
And I don't know how much
of this trial was public
and how much of it
wasn't, but I was
at a meeting of these Russians,
and a man came up behind me
and put something
into my pocket.
And he said, don't look at it
until you get to your room.
And I went back to my hotel.
And I put in the computer.
And it was the entire trial
and all the depositions.
And then I had to fly
home to the US with this.
I was like, is this even
something I'm supposed to have?
I have no idea.
But I didn't get arrested.
So anyway, it was
an amazing story.
And I did have access to a lot
of really great information.
But in general, I'm not really
naming sources in this one.
AUDIENCE: OK.
I guess just a more
general question about it
then, about the
sources you did have.
How were they as people?
BEN MEZRICH: Yes.
You know what?
Very pleasant.
I get blamed for this a lot.
I love the people I write
about in every book.
I think it was Janet
[? Mazen ?] who
said I'm like the evil
billionaire's best friend.
But the reality is is
that I like people,
and I like people who are open.
And what I like most
about people like this
is that they're not fake.
You know what?
You see right up front
who these people are.
There's no lying going on.
They tell you exactly
how they made their money
and where they got it from.
And hearing the stories like
that, it was an amazing thing.
So in general, I actually
got along well with them.
There was one person I was
working with for a long time.
And then as I did my research,
I was like, holy crap.
This guy was, like, heavy.
This guy was a tough
guy, but in person,
very kind and very smart.
And I learned a lot.
For the most part,
these are very smart,
ambitious people who are
living in a very Wild West--
they call it the
Wild East-- society,
where there weren't the
same sort of rules you
have in the West in business.
They said, don't look
at the '90s in Russia
like the '90s in America.
Look at the '90s in Russia
like the 1890's in America,
where people were shooting
each other on the street.
This was a world in which if
you were the CEO of a company,
and the CEO of another
company came against him,
and you killed him,
you got his company.
That doesn't happen
in American business.
There's a board of directors.
It doesn't get you the company.
But in Russia, at the time,
it did get you the company.
There's a great
story in the book--
and this is all true--
where the oil company
they were building,
they needed what's
called a red director,
which was a communist leader
of a piece of a company, to
OK the deal they were making.
So they went to meet
with this guy in Siberia.
He's an Old World Communist guy.
And it was Abramovich
and Berezovsky.
Berezovsky had lunch with him.
And they said, we need
you to OK this deal.
And this guy said, no, I'm
not going to OK this deal.
So they went back to Moscow.
That night, that man went
swimming in the Irkutsk River
in the middle of
Siberia, drowned.
His bodyguard, who was the only
witness, got into a bar fight
and died.
And then the deal went through.
So I hear this story.
And I'm like, well, that
sounds a little shady, right?
And they guy goes, yes, it
was much trouble for us.
Everyone assumed
we had him killed.
[LAUGHTER]
I don't know.
But that was the story.
He went and he drowned.
It happens.
The way they described
it, he was a big man.
He was macho.
He had these girls with him.
He wanted to impress them.
He jumped in the water.
It was cold.
He had a heart attack.
It happens.
So the story is there.
It's an incredible story.
But in the scope
of this story, this
happened over and
over and over again,
where the person
in your way died.
Something would happen.
And it was a lesson,
but everyone kind of
knew the game they were playing.
That's the other
thing about this.
Nobody was a businessman
in Russia in the '90s
and didn't realize that this
is how this game worked.
They all had security
of 50, 60 men.
Every company had a
division of wetworks
whose job it was to deal with
security issues, anything
from protecting a
CEO to bashing up
a showroom of another company.
So that's how business
was working in the '90s.
It was very corrupt and chaotic.
And Abramovich had a
great quote in the trial,
where they ask him
about this and he says,
well, this was the
world we were in.
I mean, this was how it worked.
Was it corrupt?
Was it chaotic?
Sure.
But we were all
businessmen in the world
with these sorts of rules.
So your choice was
to be a businessman
or not be a businessman.
So I actually am
intrigued by that.
I could never do
anything like that.
I'm scared of everything.
But the idea to me is these were
very upfront, ruthless people
working in a very
ruthless, upfront society.
So I don't know.
There's something
appealing to me about that.
AUDIENCE: Do you
multitask at all?
So when you work
on this project,
do you have things lined up?
BEN MEZRICH: I do.
I have a lot of projects
going on at the same time,
more than one should have.
I have four movies
in development,
a television show with
FX and Jerry Bruckheimer
based on my book
"Ugly Americans."
Some of you might have
heard of this book,
about expats living in Asia and
the Japanese sex underground.
But it's also about bankers
in Tokyo around 2000--
although we're updating it, so
it's like "Entourage" in Asia
now.
So the show is
going to be called--
I don't know what it's
going to be called,
but it's based on my
book "Ugly Americans."
So I'm working on multiple
projects, and then this book,
and then another
project as well.
So I do have a lot going on.
I try and focus until
something is done
and then move to the next one.
But in general, it's
impossible, because if you
have multiple things going--
so yeah, I multitask a lot.
But it's more like just
crazed, wild, this and this
and this and this.
It's not a controlled
multitasking.
I'm not like one of those people
who keeps a book, and this 15
minutes, I'm doing this, and
there's 15 minutes of that.
I should be one of those people.
But instead I'm just
doing this-- oh, shoot,
I have to do that.
Oh, shoot, I have to do that.
And then somehow,
it all gets done.
I don't recommend this form
of working for anybody,
but this is what I do.
Yeah.
Sure.
AUDIENCE: So there's
this point in your story
that seems like this lacuna
that you don't quite believe.
It begins with-- so
you meet Ma in a bar.
And I knew people who knew some
of these people back at MIT.
They didn't just,
like, tell everybody
in a bar what they did.
So there was some
conversation you had.
And then you said,
oh, come back to my--
Somehow, like, yeah, you
just-- and then these people
tell you all their secrets.
Some I'm curious what you
can tell us about that.
BEN MEZRICH: I'm very
ingratiating, first of all.
I think people in
general-- I don't
go in with a notebook
or a tape recorder
and get people to
tell me their stories.
First of all, it's people who
want to tell their stories.
People come to me
all the time and say,
you know what would
make a great story?
FIFA, all the craziness in FIFA.
Well, yeah, that would
make a great story.
But I need a guy who
wants to tell the story.
And Jeff was a guy who
wanted to tell the story.
I met Jeff through
the girl on the team,
who introduced me to them.
She was the one that
Kate Bosworth ended up
playing in the movie, Jane.
She's here in Boston, too.
She's at Ropes & Gray,
a big-time lawyer now.
She was dating one of the
MIT blackjack members.
Now, I didn't know that.
I didn't know that she
was a blackjack player.
She was actually one of
the best blackjack players.
And she basically
ended up saying,
you got to meet these guys.
So I met them,
saw all the money,
and then started
following Jeff around.
Jeff wanted to tell his story.
It wasn't like twisting his arm.
Although there was a point
right before the book
came out that
suddenly he realized
this was going to happen.
He was like, let's
just cancel this.
I don't want to do this anymore.
And I was like, Jeff, this
is coming out in a week.
You don't have a
choice anymore, Jeff.
But I do become friends
with these characters.
I become part of their lives.
As I said, Eduardo was
dating my wife's best friend
and we were hanging out.
That's how I write my stories.
So when someone
pitches me a story,
I'm also trying to figure
out how close to this person
can I get.
And sometimes it works out
and sometimes it doesn't.
Sometimes it becomes
an awful situation,
where you're with
someone for a long time
and you realize this is going to
go bad somewhere along the way.
But that's the way
I write my stories,
is I become a part of it.
I join into whatever group
it is I'm writing about.
With the Russian oligarchs,
it was much trickier.
I got along very well
with a lot of the people
I was working with.
But in the back of
your head, you're
thinking, well, what
have these people done?
Who are these people really?
But in general, I try and find
a way to get inside their head
and get very close to them.
And so in the end, they
really want to talk.
And I will say the
movie thing helps a lot.
Almost everyone wants to
see themselves in a movie.
Everyone thinks that their
story needs to be on the screen.
And a lot of people's story
could be on the screen.
And so essentially,
when I go into it,
people know that there's a
chance it could be a movie.
They'll be more
talkative and more open.
Other people, of course,
immediately clam up,
people who don't want
their story told.
And I know when that's
going to happen.
I'm like, OK, this person
is not going to talk to me.
But the MIT team
that I worked with,
they all really wanted
their story out there.
So yeah.
Sure.
AUDIENCE: You
mentioned oligarchs
trying to put their money in
safe places, such as New York
real estate.
And before the talk,
you said something
which seemed
particularly fascinating,
which is American movies
as a particularly big focus
for oligarchs.
BEN MEZRICH: Yeah,
so Brett knows
a lot of these guys
personally, which
is how we got into the story.
There's a lot of Russian
money in Hollywood.
There are people with enormous
amounts of money-- and not just
the oligarchs with
their billions,
but multi-millionaires
from Russia--
who want to make movies.
And the honest truth
is that Hollywood
will take money from anybody.
It doesn't matter who you
are or what you've done.
If you're willing to put a
few million dollars into movie
that will probably not make
any money, you're welcome.
You can be a producer.
So a lot of money is coming
in from Russia into Hollywood.
And so that's where this story
probably was connected into.
But yes, there's a lot
of money going into--
and to a lot of industries.
I mean, listen.
You know, there's hundreds
of these billionaires,
essentially, now from
countries like Russia and China
and the Middle East whose
countries are not that safe.
So where are they going
to put their money?
They're going to
move it all here.
Which makes it hard
for regular people
to buy apartments in
Boston now, right,
but that's essentially where
all this money is coming from.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So now that you
have a personal connection
to the Brooklyn Nets,
I hope that you will
be moving into spots stuff.
And I'm sure you're hard at work
on the FIFA scandal right now.
That would be the
obvious next project.
I actually have two questions.
I hope that's OK.
BEN MEZRICH: Sure.
AUDIENCE: And
actually, one question
is a little obliquely
related to this.
People often put you
and Michael Lewis
in the same category Jonathan
did when he introduced you.
There's some obvious
similarities there,
although Michael Lewis's
subjects seem a little more
staid than a lot of yours.
But I'm just wondering if you
have any kind of relationship
at all with Michael
and have ever
thought about doing
anything collaborative.
And that leads me to
the second question,
which is-- I'm not clear.
Have you ever done any
actual screenwriting?
And would you want to do that?
Have you tried it?
Do you do it?
That's certainly an
area where people often
collaborate with each other.
But anyway, those are my
two questions, Michael Lewis
and screenwriting.
BEN MEZRICH: Yeah.
So Michael Lewis, first of
all, one of the greatest
writers around today.
And he has Wall
Street covered so well
that I can't do Wall
Street unless I find
something he wouldn't touch.
I think he's amazing.
I'm very competitive and
sad that he's so much more
successful than me.
I think Michael's brilliant.
He's a genius.
I have never worked with him.
I've never met him.
He's my younger brother's
favorite author,
which bothers me to no end.
Every time I write a
book, my little brother
calls me and goes, it's good,
but it's no Michael Lewis.
But yeah, he's amazing.
And I would love
to work with him,
I just don't know how that
would ever come about.
In terms of screenwriting,
I've written one screenplay,
for my book "Ugly Americans."
I had written it for 2929
or DreamWorks at the time,
I can't remember.
It didn't get made, and now
it's being made into a show.
So I'm not writing that.
I will write screenplays, but
I'll always be a book writer.
I love the idea of
doing a screenplay,
and I probably will do it.
I think the process is very
tough, and in many ways,
demeaning.
You write it, and
there's a whole committee
of people that work with you
and change it, change it,
and change it, and change it.
And it never gets made.
There's hundreds of
working screenwriters
who make good livings who've
never had a movie made.
And that would be incredibly
frustrating to me.
With a book, you write the book.
For better or worse,
you control it.
It comes out.
Whether people buy it or not,
you don't have a lot of control
over.
But it's your
project, and then they
can make a movie out of it.
I will do screenplays.
I'd like to adapt some
of my own projects.
In general, Hollywood does
not want you to do that.
When you sell a
project, they want
to attach an A-list
screenwriter to it.
And that's the quickest
way a movie gets made.
So you usually say
yes, because the goal
is to get a movie made.
If I wanted to, I could
say, no, I want to write it.
They would say, sure.
They'd let me write it, and then
they would hire a screenwriter.
So usually that's what happens.
But I will eventually
try my hand
in a bigger way
in screenwriting.
I think it's a very
different format.
You don't get all the
interior dialogue.
You don't get a lot of the
stuff that you get in a book.
But on the other hand,
my books are always,
for better or worse,
called cinematic.
I think my very
first book review--
when I was 25 years old, in
"The New York Times"-- it said,
this is a bad book.
Someone should make
it into a movie.
So I think from
the very beginning,
I've always been seen
as someone who writes
books that could be movies.
So eventually, I probably
will do more screenplays.
But also, the reality is I
never want to leave Boston.
I love the city.
This is where I live.
And to be a working
screenwriter,
eventually you end up in LA.
And that's not for me.
I love LA for a week.
But beyond that, I got
to come back to Boston.
So yeah, so far so good.
And Michael Lewis,
listen, anytime
he wants to do
something, I'm here.
But he's great.
I think he's an amazing writer.
Anybody else, question?
Sure.
AUDIENCE: I was just wondering,
which work are you most proud,
and why?
BEN MEZRICH: Yeah.
I would say "Once Upon a Time in
Russia" I think is in many ways
my first adult book.
It's my first book
of a serious topic.
I did an interview for
the BBC the other day.
And they're like, so
tell me about glasnost.
And I was like, holy
shit, what did I do?
I can't tell anybody
about glasnost.
But I think "Bringing
Down the House"
was the book that was
most, like, amazing to me.
It changed my life.
I was out in Vegas.
I wrote this.
It was my first nonfiction
book, and it did very well.
So that was a book
I'm very proud of.
I think "Ugly Americans"
is a great story.
Japan was amazing.
I spent a month over there
and was just blown away by it.
And I thought that was
a lot of fun to write.
I wrote a book called "Sex on
the Moon," which we're still
trying to make into a
movie, about a kid who
stole moon rocks from NASA.
And it's a really wild
"Catch Me if You Can"
type of story, where he
stole the 600-pound safe
full of moon rocks from every
moon landing in history.
And he spread them on a bed
and had sex with his girlfriend
on the moon, and then
tried to sell the moon
rocks over the internet.
And it's this wild,
bizarre true story.
He ended up spending 10
years in prison for what to
him was like a college prank.
And then the day he got out
of prison, he called me.
And he was like, I want
to tell you a story.
And I was meeting
this guy who had just
been in prison a decade.
And I was, like, all scared.
And he's like the
nicest guy, super smart.
He was on his way to
being an astronaut
and had just done
something really stupid.
And I was kind of just
interested in that.
And I think that book
came together very well.
So "Sex on the Moon"
was a good one.
But yeah, I think
that people will like
"Once Upon a Time in Russia."
I think it's going to
make an awesome movie.
So hopefully that's
a project that people
will look at and like.
Anybody else?
AUDIENCE: So you mentioned
"Once Upon a Time in Russia"
as your first adult book
or sort of serious topic.
Are you hoping anything comes
of it beyond a movie and people
reading it?
Are you hoping that will cause
any changes here or in Russia
or anything like that?
BEN MEZRICH: Well, listen.
I do want to preface this
by saying, first of all,
that this is probably the
most pro-Putin book you're
going to read from an American
author around this time.
Because in the
scope of this story,
Putin is not the bad guy.
He came to this
country at a time
when everything
was falling apart.
Oligarchs had all
this wealth and money.
Nobody knew what to
do with capitalism.
And he took power, basically
saying, no more taking
the money out of this country.
This country is going to get
great and strong and powerful
again.
And I'm going to wipe out
anybody who says no to that.
So in the scope of the
story, he's not the bad guy.
But I will say-- do I want
anything serious to happen
because of this book?
You know, that's
a good question.
I don't ever sit
down and think, how
is going to affect the world?
Am I going to change policy?
Is anything going to
happen because of this?
I just don't take myself
that seriously in general.
I write thrillers, you know.
I write fun,
entertaining stories.
I do think people will get a
better perception of Putin,
a better, more real
perception of how this all
happened by reading this book.
Because you really don't see
a lot in the news about where
he came from.
You really don't see
a lot in the news
about why he's so powerful,
or why these oligarchs are
all in London.
And I feel like this
is the first time
the story is told in this
way, or at least in a big way.
Yeah, I don't know.
I don't have the solution to
all the problems in Russia.
It's such a complicated
issue, the world as it is now
and how Russia is dealing
with the Ukraine and all
this kind of stuff.
I just think reading
this book will
help people have a better
understanding of that period
in time, the '90s.
But no, for me it's
really entertainment.
In the end, I'm an
entertainer, I think.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
BEN MEZRICH: Yes.
Hey.
AUDIENCE: OK, so
connected to that,
do think that when it goes
from your book to your movie,
the general sort of
sentiment is preserved?
And do you think it will be
in this movie about Putin
and Russia?
BEN MEZRICH: Yeah,
a great question.
So for me, I sell
the project, and I
hope I sell it to the people
who will make the best movie out
of it.
Because once you
sell it as an author,
you're on the lowest
part of the totem pole.
You're below the caterer.
You're not important.
And they don't want-- they want
you to hang out there, and sit
at the bar, and hang out with
the actors, and then go away.
I always say the
producer's favorite author
is a dead author,
because then they
don't have to deal with them.
So in general, I've
been very lucky.
I thought "21" was really fun.
A lot of people say the book
was more serious blackjacky
and the movie was more fluffy.
But I think the movie "21"
was kind of perfect for what
it was.
Every 21-year-old kid watched
it on the way to Vegas.
It was fun.
It was exciting.
And I thought Spacey was great.
And then "The Social
Network" was brilliant.
Sorkin and Fincher did an
amazing thing with that story,
beyond anything I
could have hoped for.
So I've been very fortunate.
I didn't have a lot of control.
I was consulting.
I talked a lot on the
set to everyone involved
and was involved
in that respect,
but I didn't have any real
control over anything.
But sooner or later,
a bad movie will
be made from one of my books.
I believe this is going
to be a very good movie.
We've got a lot of
really amazing people
who are interested in
doing it right now.
So I don't know yet who the
specific director or writer
will be.
But I know the people in
contention are phenomenal.
So I do think this will
be a very big project.
It's at Warner's now.
And Warner's will
make the decision
very shortly of who's going
to write and direct it.
And I think it's going
to move very quickly.
So I do think it's
going to be good.
But it's early.
It's early, and you
never really know.
And we'll see what happens.
I've been lucky.
I know I've been lucky.
I have a lot of friends
in the business who've
had movies made of their books
that didn't come out so well.
And "The Social Network" is just
one of those crazy situations,
where suddenly you have this
Oscar-winning movie based
on Facebook.
Who knew, right?
So it's something
that worked out.
Sure.
AUDIENCE: I'm a little intrigued
by what you said just recently,
that you just
write to entertain.
In our book club we read
another story about Russia
by this guy Bill
Browder, "Red Notice."
And I was struck by how
he, as a Wall Street
money-making guy went to
Russia, did all this stuff.
And then when his
lawyer gets jailed,
decided completely to change
his life, to write a book,
to go to Congress and
actually get his act passed.
So how have these stories
kind of changed you?
BEN MEZRICH: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: And I hope you
don't say, no, I just write--
BEN MEZRICH: Well, his story
is fascinating and incredible.
And I think he's a
very brave man who
went through something intense.
And his lawyer was
murdered, died in prison.
And then he wrote that book
as a way of protest, in a way,
to really make something happen.
He and I are very different.
This is my 17th book.
I write books because
the story compels me,
and it's fascinating.
It's interesting and intriguing.
I live vicariously
through the characters.
You know, I wanted to be
the MIT kid taking on Vegas.
I wanted to be Mark Zuckerberg.
I wanted to be an oligarch
while I was writing the book.
The idea is fascinating to me.
So yes and no.
Does it change me?
I have to explain
me a little bit.
And I know this is a
weird thing to say,
but I'm a very neurotic,
bizarre person.
And in my regular life,
I'm like a hermit.
I don't really
want to go outside.
I live in the mall, and I
don't ever leave the mall.
I'm like a very pale,
tiny little creature.
And yet when I write a
book, I become a part of it.
I live this incredibly
amazing life,
where I'm flying
around in private jets.
And I'm in Sean Parker's
limo for the night.
And I'm running around
like whatever character
I'm writing about.
I'm hanging out in
[? yukuza ?] bars in Osaka.
And so I live like
the characters
for that period in time
when I'm writing the book.
And then the book ends,
and I go back to me.
So no, in a way, the books
don't affect who is me.
But during the process
of writing the book,
I become whatever it
is I'm writing about.
I know it sounds strange.
I always worshipped
Hunter S. Thompson.
And I wanted to be
But I wanted to be
him without the drugs
and the guns and the suicide.
I always liked the
safe version of him.
And I feel like by
compartmentalizing
my life, that's what I do.
So I can become him
for a little bit,
and then I go back
to my regular life.
So yeah, in a way, it's
sad because there's
no personal growth.
But on the other
hand, there's lots
of moments of personal growth,
and then I quickly pull back
into who I am.
So I guess that's the
answer, which may not
be what you're looking for.
But it's kind of
what works for me.
And that's why this book has
been a phenomenal experience.
And then I move on to the next
project, if that makes sense.
But yeah.
Sure.
AUDIENCE: What is
your next story?
BEN MEZRICH: Yeah,
the next story.
So I'll be on tour for
this for a little while,
for the next few weeks.
And I have a book I just sold,
and a movie as well, called
"The 37th Parallel," which
will be out next year, which
is a really wild, true
story about a guy who is
known as the Mulder of El Paso.
He's a sheriff's deputy in
Colorado, El Paso, Colorado,
who became obsessed with UFOs.
And it's not about UFOs,
but it's really more
like "Close Encounters."
This obsession kind
of became his life.
He has a couple kids.
He gets an RV.
And on his days off, he
takes them off to UFO sites,
where people have seen
UFOs, to investigate.
They check into a motel.
And he gets his Glock and goes
out in the middle of the night
to look for UFOs.
And while doing this,
he kind of uncovered
something really bizarre.
And it ties all the
way into the CIA,
and all the things
we've heard about,
and all the bizarre
conspiracy things.
But it all comes back
to this simple story
of this guy and his family
and what he uncovered.
I don't want to
give too much away,
because this is really early.
But that's going to be
the next project for me.
And I'm working on
that over the summer.
Anybody else?
AUDIENCE: Is that fiction?
BEN MEZRICH: True.
True story.
He's the real
"Close Encounters."
I mean it's a story
that will really
be mind-boggling
to a lot of people,
because what he
discovered-- it's
very clearly that something
bizarre is going on.
But what it is is
still undecided.
But it's really interesting.
I'll give you one
little snippet.
Whenever the FAA gets a report
of a UFO sighting by a pilot,
that information is actually
sent to a private company,
an aeronautics
company that actually
makes gaskets for the
International Space Station.
This company funds
a UFO response team.
And so that's all true.
So just think about
that for a second.
That's bizarre.
And yet that is something
that is part of this story.
So there is something going
on, but it's not necessarily
UFOs and aliens and
stuff like that.
But there is a lot of
money and a lot of interest
in these bizarre things.
And I think that that's
fascinating, for whatever
reason it might be.
Sure.
Awesome.
Well, listen, thank you so much.
This was great.
I'll hang out here and
sign whatever you want.
And if anybody has any
questions up front and personal,
I'm good to go.
So thank you so much.
I appreciate it.
[APPLAUSE]